comme un bon jour alors de quoi est il
question très exactement l'écouté le
conseil des ministres s'est achevée il
ya quelques instants et on attend
désormais la traditionnelle conférence
de presse pour en savoir plus sur les
mesures qui ont été retenues par le
gouvernement ce qu'on sait en tout cas
c'est que les ministres ont entériné la
prolongation de l'état d'urgence
sanitaire pour une période de deux mois
à partir du 24 mai ce qui conduit cet
état d'urgence sanitaire au moins
jusqu'au 23 juillet prochain
c'est un cadre légal qui permet au
gouvernement d'avoir des pouvoirs
étendus dans sa lutte contre la pandémie
de kobe de 19 alors dans le texte qui a
été discutée aujourd'hui certains une
certaine mesure ont déjà fuité dans la
presse parmi lesquels un système
d'isolement des personnes testées
positives on ne sait pas encore si cette
mesure sera finalement retenue dans le
texte final il se pourrait par exemple
que cela ne concerne que les français et
les étrangers qui arriverait sur le
territoire national et qui pourrait donc
être placé à l'isolément
autre mesure qui fait débat c'est un
système d'information pour identifier
les personnes infectées il fait débat
parce que pour un certain nombre
d'observateurs et de membres de
l'opposition il s'agit là d'une atteinte
aux libertés publiques
et puis le gouvernement qui doit
également répondre à un certain nombre
d'interrogations sur l'après 11 mai sur
le déconfinement avec notamment cette
question peut-on pourra-t-on circuler
d'un département à l'autre selon que ce
département est classé vert au rouge
voilà entre autres une des
interrogations que devra lever le
gouvernement ce samedi pour avec ce
texte donc qui sera pour sa part
présenté lundi au sénat avant d'être
discuté à l'assemblée nationale dans le
courant de la semaine prochaine
merci beaucoup de m'abonner pour tout
fait précision en direct donc de
l'elysée chien